home a live look now from reed
international ahead of one of the
busiest travel weekends of the year of
course we're talking about fourth of
july now all eyes are on the airlines
right now as issues with some of the
nation's top carriers could cause major
headaches for millions of passengers
well today alone more than 650 domestic
flights have been canceled nationwide
this according to flightaware jeremy j
ford is live on this story he's over at
reed international with how travelers
are being impacted right here at home
now look if you guys are traveling to or
from las vegas this summer you might be
want to be aware of cancellations and
delays
[Music]
next time just don't load us on the
plane benjamin spielman made his way
from medford to las vegas on monday
afternoon and his flight wasn't without
turbulence our flight ended up just
getting canceled
it took a while they were like they kept
postponing it over and over again an
inconvenience for passengers like
christian conk who traveled with her
family and was delayed for almost 24
hours well my husband is freaking out
right now because he's got work he's
stressing out a lot we've got my son
also who lives in utah was heading back
to utah and he didn't make it back for
work so he missed work as well
just a little stressful you know putting
a damper on her plans and leaving her
family to consider other options they
got to do something about it or it's
going to be
you know people are going to start
finding other ways to travel with a word
of advice to would-be travelers just
plan
knowing that there's a good chance your
flight might get canceled
now some of the passengers that were on
that edward medford flight from
medford into las vegas that's flight 142
said they got vouchers and even hotel
stay to be to compensate them for their
travel delays jeremy j ford live local
now
so what are your rights if your flight
is delayed or cancelled according to the
us department of transportation you are
guaranteed a seat on the next available
flight and then a refund for the unused
portion of your ticket